for
spe
hold this as close to you as possible
because it is definitely a challenge
when um when it's like not right up to
your face but I think it'll be good
we'll adjust as needed if we need to we
might give you are you cating a lot no
okay that might be the backup option but
I want to hear you I mean I I won't
project it shouldn't can we um rather
than me manhandle you can we get this
closer up or is that bad for feedback
let's see I've never had to deal with
the second mic so things you're ining
another variable jar you know I like
make if you don't cry before an event
that I do then it's not right yeah you
me get like above that but
% I'll
take thanks just I want to make sure the
video is good everyone at home yeah I
was just saying toley
that if this
is okay I mean three microphones four
microphones I one of both hand that's
fine should his might be pointed up
though well I'm trying to get it closer
to his
face uh
a little here let me let me just try
something really
quickly
uh I'm trying to see how we even got
this in here okay give me one
sec I kind of want to get it through
here that's what yeah that's what I
sorry I'm going just take this out right
now
how does that even happen you know what
maybe if like pull it apart a little I
tried to get it through there before too
but
this that's where it should go yeah all
right give me one
sec there's any way we can I'll be right
back let me see if I
can
I don't know I don't know how this came
out this came loose in the first place
yeah some here let me check heavy
mystery
e
all awesome you too how are
things here p you have great B here
tonight yeah are you going to do a
costume I did one we can't have any
handing up we don't do that yeah
we you pardon else with you tonight no
just here yeah are you doing class in
your yeah I did one today and yesterday
oh I see yeah so that's what I was here
for how big is the class now I was
70 oh
the what I have 10 was 40 yeah it's got
a lot bigger yeah Coley I'm sorry do I'm
going to give you the handheld is that's
okay just because I want to make sure
people hear you and we just have not had
very good luck with this m p and then
like 5 minutes into your talk people are
going to say they can't hear me hear you
and then I'm going to yeah just I mean I
can manage I'm not a huge fan of
handouts but I'll can make it work okay
thank you sorry about that at least I'm
not yeah it should be
okay
sit Downes okay uh can you switch on the
uh pack yeah I already switched on to
yeah all right guys get started find
your
seats
for
try again
all right everyone if you can make your
way towards your seats we're going to
get started with few announcements of
giveaway so please come uh take a few
seats nice silence in the crowd
aw all right so thank you everyone for
coming everyone's very excited we all
know why you're
here so to get started always like to
say who is hiring any
jobs right in the
back
speak
loudly would you like me give a little
int say what say what you're hiring for
oh yeah so if you like pizza I'm a lot
of you
do we are my pizza and we're looking for
data science data analysts
scientists anyone interested you like
pizza
flat iron few people here all
right
like so I I work at the hbert center for
Workforce Development at Ru University
and we're hiring uh data
scientists admin
dat I I work my way to
back
I York dat
science we a data team Kickstarter
Focus
onar all right one
more I do just want to point out that
we're in New York we have so many
Healthcare not a single Finance
guy Benny is not here one more so if you
like diamond we have a manager of data
science position
all right wonderful and since we all
know you like pizza we want to know how
much you like pizza so if everyone could
take out their
smartphones or their Internet connected
laptops or tablets whatever you got and
go to bit.ly SL Pizza
Pole we for those of you who don't know
and those of you do I'm reiterating
we've been tracking the monthly pizza
here for the past 4 years there yeah see
the top of the page is a lovely D3 chart
there generated by chart our charts so
all art code that generated the D3 to
show this the data gets stored in a uh
myle database and the feed is available
to you in Json if you want to do your
own data
manipulation so if anyone wants that
I'll get you the Source I said find the
link but bitly Pizza pull rank the pizza
excellent good fa average for never
again the pizza is from Fior down bleer
street um it is based on if anyone's
ever heard of Joe and P down in Sten
island famous piz from the 60s it's
exact it's almost exact happy even down
to the oven so everyone please
vote uh next up you probably saw on the
table on the way in we have more of
those NC data Mafia NR and I T-shirts
they for sale Joe will happily sell you
one for 20 bucks they will go to the
Meetup and I to pay Drew Conway and Adam
Hogan who n anyone remember Drew
Conway yeah of course you do yeah and
Adam Hogan he was here for a while but
unfortunately went back to Chicago he's
doing well he is that's good to
hear great um for those of you who want
to attend strata that's coming up in
just a few weeks if you want a discount
code because Hadley told me earlier
never pay full for anything
O'Reilly so if you want code ug NY
R20 a very long discount code you can
find it on the me page and all our
postings ug NY half hour2 for a discount
toal Rising if people want to remember
that I will give you a little postcard
in fact you take
half take more and sort of throw them at
people
all right
thank next up there is this only applies
to students so I'm sorry I know students
the MBA is having a hackathon about
basketball analytics so if any students
here wants to participate in an NBA
basketball
hackathon go to the announcement the
discussion board for the Meetup group
and there's a link to it there I think
it's like MBA hackathon but go find the
link and you can sign up for that it's
going be a lot of fun big analytics
there so definitely go check that
out after the Meetup whenever we're done
we're going to go to Ry house everyone
here remember Ry
house a little
TPP regulars they all know where Ry
house is but the non-re we will leave
you there there
amazing great whiskey S I think they
have but I know um and they have good
food so everyone go to R house after
this um before I do the rest of
announcements I want to thank workbench
for letting us pack so many people into
Lely space and not killing me I think
Jess good evening
everyone welcome my name is Jessica Lynn
I prly been here or attended our New
York art conference
awesome around the GoPro her
head
very thrilled to have you for this very
special meet up
tonight Our God our
God so very excited to have you all with
us for those of you who are new to
workbench we are an Enterprise focused
Venture fund and Community which means
that we love startups that are using
data and analytics to build
transformative software for a large
portion of 1000 companies so if you're
on the startup side if you're on the
corporate side or to connect with some
awesome Enterprise startups we here at
workbench would love to chat so with
that a very big thank you again and have
a great Mee thank you J everyone Round
of Applause to
workbench just a few more announcements
and giveaways I'll let you get to happy
uh October next month our speaker is
going to be the infamous JD long right
back there
he once gave a talk at a conference all
in the style of Dr
Seuss and in his bio he sent me James
writes poorly commented inefficient code
using python R SQL and
xlo so you know that it's going to be an
amazing talk in
October um in November the day before
the election we will have Hillary Parker
and David Robinson analyzing the test of
the
candidates so D Rob you're here right d
Rob if you guys don't know him he's one
came became famous recently for
analyzing Donald Trump's tweets and
finding out the angry Android ones were
him and the nicer yeah that's
him okay next up oh if anyone wants our
markdown cheat sheets we got them
here
so oh I see a hand up Hadley can you
deliver the first
one and I'll do the same thing I'll
split this up whoever wants them wants
them whoever doesn't just don't leave
them on the floor take half please and
I'll take another half over here if you
want one grab before take it cool all
right next up sorry guys I got to get
through this stuff I know it's taking a
while but we got to do this we have
books to give away anyone have a Sharpie
on them by the
way who a Sharpie throw it up here you
have one on you wonderful you're going
to need it so we're going to give away
our
packages yeah we have three of
them so first up draw randomly using the
sample function in
r with a seed that was set four weeks
ago the last time I set a
seed James
beverge yes come on down
down come on
down we're going to make this a very
inefficient process oh score thank you
think you got to cover you got to cover
thank you so much thank you for the
everyone Applause for the
PS all right next up Bonnie
Ray Bonnie Ray James right all right
clipp
La really we have this many no shows
wait wait can someone check is that
really
Clipper all right got clipp right here
for his copy of our packages got a pose
someone take a
picture tweet it please tweet it #
rstats over here over here
oh
that reminds me they did want me to
say NYC data Mafia all right come on
everyone hashtag us up then the last
copy of our packages by Hadley
W we're applauding for you that means
you have to be
here all right you lost your chance
David
Crawford oh you're actually here though
all but you won so you're declined cuz
you won yeah you won this didn't you
oh Riley sent me a lot of
copies all right Mike
Lawrence
last
seriously all right ready that's a
terrible idea I'm not going to throw it
am I allowed to throw things in it no
she's like
Mommy Kos
ready all
right oh there we
go and you have one suspiciously large
amount of stuff
too well luckily he was my student so I
trust
him #
that's all
right all right and we have a tradition
here for some reason I don't know why we
keep giving Hadley t-shirts every time
he
speaks we Mafia t-shirt we gave him an
iror t-shirt and today we are giving him
an NYC data bikers
t-shirt you can see this is our code see
do data do bikers gets Pizza Plus ice
cream plus
bike and the back is a biker so
concerned holding their ice cream and
their Pizza they're not
biking so heavily enjoy
thanks and this one I have to because my
friend Kirk metler who doesn't seem to
be here tonight made this and I just
have to embarrass
Hadley
yep yep it's still on more probably will
remain that way but it's going to get
rained one
day so with that thank you everyone very
much I hope you have a wonderful time
and I present to you Hy
W thanks Jared so the room's a little
large so I'll kind of give you 50/50 or
I could stand right in the middle where
it's uncomfortable for
everyone but so today I want to talk
about the Tidy verst which is kind of an
ecosystem of packages that are designed
to make data science or data analysis
easier and I whenever I talk about data
data science I always show this diagram
because I think it's really useful to
think about what are the tools you need
to do data science and to me they really
are kind of have to count these
carefully uh seven key tools for doing
data science so first of all you have
have to start by importing your data
you've got to get it out of whatever
crazy format your collaborators have
stored in and into r or whatever data
analysis environment you're
using now once you've done that you need
to I think it's a really good idea to
tidy it or store your data in a
consistent format that's important
basically because it's going to save you
a lot of time because if you store
things consistently rather than having
to sort of think about every time how do
I access a variable how do I access an
observation you've got one consistent
way of doing it
then you'll often do some transformation
that's things like creating new
variables that are functions of existing
variables or Computing summaries where
you collapse down many values to a
single value then after that there
really are two main engines of data
Discovery visualization and
modeling so visualization is great
because it's a fundamentally a human
activity a visualization can surprise
you you can see something that you did
not expect and you can also use
visualizations to help you refine your
question questions of the data the
problem with visualizations however is
that because they are a human activity
they don't scale very well a human brain
has to look at every visualization so as
you get more and more data or more and
more visual more and more variables you
can't look at every possible
visualization so to me the complimentary
tool to visualization is modeling
modeling is a fundamentally a
computation or mathematical or
statistical tool which once you've made
your your question sufficiently precise
you can answer it very efficiently or
even if it's not very efficiently you
can just throw more and more computers
at the
problem but every every model by its
very by its nature makes assumptions and
a model cannot question those
assumptions so that means in some
fundamental sense a model can never
surprise you so models scale well they
don't surprise you visualizations don't
scale well but they do surprise you so
in any real analysis you're going to do
both modeling and visualization again
and again again and
again now once you've done your
fantastic data analysis which you think
is just the most amazing and Brilliant
analysis you've ever seen it it really
doesn't matter unless you can explain
that analysis to someone else you need
to be able to communicate your
results and I think that that's a really
really important part of data science
and again that that human part of
getting the insights that You' have
built up through struggle and toil with
the data to be able to help other people
get to those insights as quickly as
possible
and then I think all of this is kind of
embedded inside tools of programming you
cannot do data analysis or data science
UN list it is on a computer so you also
need to be tools that kind of tile these
pieces together in a programming
language I think when we look at a
diagram like this it is very very easy
to look at those individual tools and
kind of forget about those arrows so
when you look at this diagram I think
you kind of you see like this you see
all the words in bold I'm going to I'm
going to import my data I'm going to
tidy it I'm going to transform I'm going
to visualize I'm going to model it I'm
going to communicate it but I think just
as important are the connections between
those tools because if those connections
are really strong and really fluid it
makes the iterative process of doing
data analysis much much much easier and
so that's what I want to talk about
tonight I want to talk about the the
Tidy
verse which is a set of packages
that are designed to work well together
that are designed so that you can spin
your precious cognitive energy focusing
on the specific challenges of your data
analysis not fighting with your tools
fighting to get the output from one
function to the input of another
function and so I want to talk about
today is sort of what I'm calling the
Tidy tools Manifesto so how do you
design tidy tools which I think is
useful if you're developing packages and
how do you like think about these tidy
tools how do you how do you use the same
ideas to make your own code your own
data analysis more
effective so I'm going to talk about uh
give you three main points for the the
the Tidy tools Manifesto so first of all
I want to talk about how important it is
to share data structures across uh
packages how important it is to solve
complex Problems by composing simple
pieces I'm going to talk about
functional programming and why you
should embrace it in other words why you
why fall Loops are bad and then I want
to talk finally again about humans that
the human is a fundamentally important
part of the process and you cannot
ignore it it's not just about the
computer you have to recognize and
embrace the limitations of the
human so I wanted to talk about talk
first about this this idea that you want
to share data structures not you don't
just want to have consistent data
structure within a package but you want
to have consistent data structures
across the packages you use and I think
one of the really important parts of
that is this idea of Tidy data and you
can po boil tidy data down to two basic
principles so first of all you want to
put each data set you have in a data
frame and then secondly you want to make
sure each variable goes in a column of
that data frame and if you follow this
principle you get what I call tidy data
or what a what a a database expert would
basically call cod's thirdd normal form
you get data that is stored a consistent
uniform way which is going to make the
rest of your data analysis process
easier now I'm going to give you guys a
little challenge which is probably going
to be a little hard because these
screens are small but one of the reasons
this is so important is because this
there's only one type of Tidy data
there's basically an infinite type
infinite number of shapes of messy data
and so tidying out messy data is really
really important because it it makes
everything else easier so I'm going to
give you this challenge this is a data
data set from the World Health
Organization uh it is some data about
cases of
tuberculosis and what I want you guys to
do is take a look at it and see if you
can figure out what are the variables in
this data set so I'm going to give you
one little hint that's F stands for
female U stands for unknown and 15
stands for 15 to 24 so what I want you
to do take a minute uh crane your Nicks
strain your eyes see if you can figure
out what are the variables in this data
set
any
okay so if you are in like the first
three rows does anyone want to volunteer
what one of the the variables in this
data set
is actual thing being
count okay so you have gone immediately
to the most difficult variable in this
data set to spot and that is the number
of cases so these counts in here in this
table these is a count the number of
cases of TB which is not explicitly
labeled anywhere what about what are
some of the easy iier variables to spot
here I think there's one that's
particularly
easy year is really easy right because
that's already a column we' got a column
next to it called ISO 2 uh you might be
able to guess from the context this is
the World Health Organization so there's
going to be data about every country ISO
2 is the iso2 lit abbreviation AD stands
for Andora so we' got three variables
right two of them year and country are
in columns we've got a third variable
that's sort of all inside this Matrix
and then we've got two other variables
that are spread across these column that
occur in the column names so we've got
the gender and the age so we've got five
variables here and they are stored in
three different ways and you can imagine
that's going to that inconsistency is
going to make it difficult to work with
this data because you have to if you
think about how would you get all the
observations corresponding to 1995 you
have to use one tool to do that what if
you wanted to find all of the years and
countries where there were five males
who had TB you'd have to use a
completely different approach so the
goal of Tidy data the goal of tidying
your data is to put it in this
consistent form and one of the packages
of the Tidy verse it helps you do that
is the Tidy r package which uh recently
I discovered uh I didn't do this
deliberately but tidy R is actually an
anagram of dirty which I think is uh
really really clever but I only did it
by accient
so here's a pipeline um we'll talk a
little bit about the uh pipeline very
shortly this idea but I'm going to read
in that data I'm going to use some tools
I'm going to gather together all of the
columns that are not variables then I'm
going to make and that's going to make
two new columns called demo short for
demographic and the number of cases I'm
going to split that apart do a little
bit more tidying up a little more
cleaning and I'm going to get this data
set so this is a tidy data set because
each variable is a column in this data
frame right and that makes life uh
easier because now everything's stored
in a consistent way you can use one tool
to do to work with it
regardless regardless of which
variable now so if your data if you do
have data of the do have variables and
observations it's a really good idea to
make sure you store as tidy data now
that's not true of every possible data
set there are lots of other things like
matrices and XML and vectors and strings
and so on but even if that's not
possible if you can't use a tidy data
frame I think it's a really good idea to
at least be
consistent now there's one other
challenge so what happens if you have
lots of different types of objects and I
think an interesting place where this
comes up is uh cross validation so in
Cross validation for example you're
going to take your data set you're going
to split into training data and test
data from that training data set you're
going to fit a model to it you're going
to combine that model with the test data
to generate predictions and then you're
going to combine the predictions with
the original values to calculate some
kind of measure of the quality of that
model like the root mean squ error so
when you do this when you do cross
validation you're not going to do it
once right you're going to do it
multiple times so how do you keep all
this information together in a way
that's easy to use and in R there's a
really neat uh technique for that and
that's to use this idea of a list column
so a data frame can store a data frame
is a list of vectors and a list is a
vector so that means one of your Columns
of a data frame can be a list so here I
have a data frame that stores a whole 90
cross validation samples I've got one
column for the training data one column
for the test data one column for the
model one column for the root mean
squared and so on so when you even when
you have more complicated objects like
models or test or training data sets you
can still store these together in a
single data frame which makes your life
much easier because now you no longer
have to worry about when you subet or
when you sort one of the vectors to sort
every other Vector in exactly the same
way now using
list columns with data frames is a
little bit challenging and that's
because I mean data frames I don't don't
get me wrong data frames are absolutely
fantastic but they have a couple of
surprising behaviors so I'm going to
give you guys a little challenge again I
want you to read this code which
hopefully everyone can actually read it
this time and I want you to think I want
you to evaluate this code in your head
so no cheating not allowed to use I I
want you to run this code in your head
and predict what the output is going to
be so talk it over with your neighbors
see if you all agree I'm going to give
you a minute starting now to evaluate
their code so if you're if you're doing
this an hour it'll be much faster but
your brain's a little
slower
IM
okay time's
up so there are two surprising things
about this bit of code so first of all
does anyone want to take a stab at what
this codee's going to going to return
yep value zero it's going to return the
numeric value zero okay what about what
else return Vector it's going to return
a vector what can you tell me anything
about that
Vector an empty Vector okay
any other
suggestions
yeah it's going to turn a factor it's
interesting uh statement so let's
actually run that
code it returns a factor that levels a
so there's two surprising behaviors of
data frames so first of all remember
data frames always like to convert your
strings to
factors and the other thing is data
frames when you index a data frame it
uses partial matching so if you give it
a unique prefix of an existing variable
name it'll return that so we don't want
to kind of like bag on b r
because it's it's not like first of all
it's not very useful but secondly these
decisions were made for a good reason I
think when you're understanding the
behavior of a Bas R and the quirks of
Bas R there are two tensions that it's
really useful to bear in mind so the
first tension is a tension between
interactive analysis and programming so
R is not just a programming language R
is also an an interactive environment
with data analysis and I think when
people if you you very experienced with
another programming language and you
come to use R people often think oh my
God R is crazy and the people have
written it must be insane that's not
entirely true um it's because R is not
just a programming language it's also an
interactive environment and there's this
there things you want in a programming
language that are great for programming
languages that are not so great for
interactive analysis so when you think
about this tension IR is kind of Base IR
is fairly far on the sort of interactive
tool it's designed to help you
understand your data interactively it's
not designed it's not the goal of our
base our is not to be the sort of most
amazing programming language that's
strict and robust that you've ever
used the other tension I think it's
really useful to bear in mind in this is
this sort of tension between
conservatism and utopianism so a
conservative right a conservative
basically wants things to stay the same
and in b r that that means that you can
write b r code if you wrote basr code
like 10 years ago the chances are today
it's still going to run so that is a
really that that conservatism is a
really strong value right because it
means code keeps on working the downside
of that is that it means if you made a
mistake 10 years ago it's very very
difficult to create that mistake so kind
of the other side of the spectrum is
utopianism so if you're a utopian you're
like well this this one little thing
isn't very good burn it all down and
start from scratch so Bas R is very much
on the kind of conservative side of
things so yes they made mistakes but and
they and our cor absolutely understands
that these are mistakes but it's very
very difficult to change them without
breaking the sort of fundamental value
of conservatism now I personally
obviously a far far more on the utopian
side and I'm very happy to burn things
down if they don't work quite right now
that that obviously has some advantages
that means you're not locked into
mistakes that you made a long time ago
but it does mean that code things are
constantly changing maybe code that you
wrote a year ago no longer works or
maybe you learned reshape and then
you're like oh my God now there's
reshape 2 I've got to learn oh no that
now reshape 2 is gone I've got to learn
tidy up right that that's the that's the
that's the
tradeoff so one of these things that
I've been working on a little bit lately
is this idea of a tibble and tibbles are
basically data frames except they are
lazy and they are
stly so what do I mean by that so if you
create a a tibble exactly the same as a
data frame we just created and you try
and access it well first of all they're
lazy they never turn uh strings into
factors no matter how much you might
want them to and if you subset them to
try and extract a single column they
always and one of the reasons I bring up
tibbles now is tibbles also make it a
little bit easier to work with list
columns so if you try and put a list in
an ordinary our data frame it thinks
that you're giving it a list of columns
basically it sort of spreads them out
wide and so you'll get an error when you
try and add a fairly simple list you can
work around that by using this I
function which tells I not to do that
but to put them in the rows instead of
the columns uh but when you print it out
it's a little hard to see what's going
on it's a little hard to hear to see
what's going on with tibles anyway but
tibles do work a little bit better with
lists and the the print method for
tibbles also tells you the type of each
column which is really really useful
particularly for verifying that your
strings haven't been turned into
factors okay so that's the principle of
sharing data structures the idea is the
more people the more packages share the
same underlying data structures the
easier it is for you to combine tools
across packages I think it's really two
really powerful ideas of this idea of
Tidy data where you put your Vari
variables in the columns and also this
idea of tibbles which is sort of a
modern reimagining of data frames which
take which keep the things that have
stood the test of time and get rid of
the things that now just more
frustrating that are more pain than
they're worth so that's the first
principle share data
structures the second principle is
compose simple pieces so the goal when
you're solving a complex problem a
really powerful way of doing that a
really and useful way of doing that is
by taking lots of little simple pieces
and combining them together and we see
this lots and lots in real life right
the the the the reason why container
ships are so successful is they kind of
take you can put whatever you like in
here but it's wrapped up in this sort of
simple consistent interface that can be
combined together and shipped all over
the world Lego is another great example
each Lego block you can look at a Lego
block and you can understand it easily
right it's very very simple you can see
how different Lego blocks connect but
your creativity is almost unlimited you
can still create very very complex
things using these simple
pieces and the thing that I think plays
this role really well in R is this is
this pipe so how many of you have seen
the pipe before or used it okay cool so
if you haven't seen it I'm going to tell
you a little story about a little bunny
named
Fufu so a little bunny fuu hopped
through the forest scooped up a field
mouse and it on the head and here I've
written that sequence of actions as if
it's a sequence of function calls and
I've kind of I've nested them as you'll
often do when you have lots of function
calls and this is a little tricky to
read because you got to read it from
inside out and the arguments of the
function end up spread quite far apart
so what the pipe allows you to do it's a
syntactic transformation from our's
perspective the code is basically the
same but it allows you to kind of flip
it so you can write these functions
almost as if they're imperative sequence
of statements little bunny fuu hops
through the forest Scoops up a field
mouse and then Bops it on the
head and this is important this idea
this this pipe potentially provides of a
unifying way of composing symbol pieces
across packages and I want to kind of
illustrate that by showing what happens
when that doesn't work or when you try
and combine D and ggplot
to so here I've got some flights data I
group it by date I sum it to count the
number of flights on each date and now I
want to visualize it I can pipe pipe
pipe oh and now I have to use
plus so that that that's a bummer
because they can't join these simple
pieces across packages I've going to got
to switch mindset halfway through and
annoyingly even gplot 2 isn't even
internally consistent so I'm creating a
plot I am adding some points I'm adding
a smooth and now I want to save
it that does not work instead you have
to write something like this which is
frankly quite
hideous now as an interesting sort of
historical Note ggplot One actually was
completely internally consistent so
ggplot one was built around this idea of
function composition and recently I kind
of bought originally was called ggplot I
call it ggplot one just to make it more
clear now I actually bought ggplot one
kind of back to life so there's not
really any reason to use it except for
kind of historical interest but the
thing that's really neat is this is how
I envisioned you would write ggplot
codes ggplot one code and the reason
that I have ggplot 2 is we switched to
plus because I pretty quickly realized
this is an unappealing code to write and
to read interestingly it works really
really well with the pipe so if I
discovered the pipe back then there
never would have been a ggplot two it
just would have been gplot one with the
pipe and just to kind of prove that it
still works here's the plot which looks
surprisingly similar to uh what you'd
see in ggplot
2 so I wanted to show another little
example um this one is from Bob rers
just showing the sort of the benefits of
the ability to chain these pieces
together across multiple packages this
is a little example of uh scraping some
unfortunately mass shooting data so it
uses five packages AV per redar deer and
lubridate you start by reading the HTML
then we extra ract all of the nodes
which have a link that starts with docs.
go so this is the first part of the URL
that will go to a Google doc then it
extracts the H the link to those Google
Docs then it uses map and read. CSV
together to read each of the csvs for
those URLs and combine them together in
a single data frame then we when we
create well we modify the date variable
to be a proper date variable in I using
the mdy function from lubridate which
passes dates in the four month day year
and then finally we assign that to a
variable called
shooting now here you'll notice I've
used the uh the rightwards assignment
Arrow which I still have exceedingly
mixed feelings about but it does feel
very very natural in the middle of the
the end of the pipe to assign the result
of that pipe to an
object okay so that was the idea of
combining simple pieces so each of these
pieces each of these fun functions is
simple you can understand it in
isolation and the way you solve complex
problems is by combining these simple
pieces together and I think one of the
things that's appealing about that that
sort of strategy is you can take like
one little step and see if you've moved
in the right direction if you haven't
moved in the right direction you take a
step back but you haven't lost much you
haven't moved very far so you can take a
little step check each time and
eventually you'll get to where you're
going I think that's that's a much more
effective way than kind of taking taking
like a very long wonder and then you
realize oh I'm in the wrong place I'm
going to back up like 15 15 minutes or
an hour's
work so the next strategy I want to talk
about is this idea of embracing
functional programming and in general
like embracing the things that make
functional programming languages so cool
or sort of another another framing of
this is why are for Loops
bad and if you've used R for a while I'm
sure someone has told you that for Loops
are bad and maybe someone has told you
that you're a bad person for using for
loops and this is absolutely not the
case like whatever code whatever code
solves your problem is good
code but I think if you just stick with
for Loops you lose out on some really
important and really powerful techniques
that will help you become a better
programmer and help you solve new
problems with ease and I'm going to
illustrate these ideas with some
cupcakes
recipes so this is a recipe for vanilla
cupcakes so how many of you made
cupcakes from scratch
before I continue to be surprised by the
number of people who come to my talks to
make
cupcakes so if you if you've never made
cupcakes before this recipe is great
because it's very very very explicit you
know it tells you to put the flour sugar
baking powder salt and a freestanding
electric mixer with a paddle attachment
and beat it on slow
speed well my favorite instruction is
turn up the mix until no sorry that's
not the my favorite instruction my
favorite instruction is continue mixing
for a couple more minutes until the
batter is smooth but do not over mix I
think you can probably take that as a
given that you should never over mix
anything like you shouldn't overcook
anything anyway so this this recipe is
great if you have never made cupcakes
before or indeed really if you've never
done any baking before but the downside
of this recipe is because it's so
verbose it's hard to see how does this
recipe from other cupcake recipes and so
here is a recipe for chocolate cupcakes
so what's the difference between vanilla
cupcakes and chocolate
cupcakes well the recipe is like 99% the
same right there's only one little
difference which is kind of hard to spot
especially since you can't read the text
but uh if I
pause the the only difference between
vanilla cupcakes and chocolate cupcakes
is that chocolate cupcakes have cocoa in
them right this is not like the this is
not the baking research discovery of the
century but it's certainly hard to see
that when you look at these two recipes
so what I'm going to do is refactor
these recipes to try and make that more
clear what the difference between these
recipes
is and the first thing I'm going to do
there's sort of an unfortunate backstory
to this this this particular recipe is
that my one of my best friends in New
Zealand uh bought this this recipe
cookbook the Hummingbird Bakery cookbook
and she made some cupcakes from and she
said they fantastic and then I bought
the cookbook here in America and I tried
making the cook the cupcakes and they
turned out terrible and that's not
because I'm a bad cook it's because I
unfortunately bought the American
version of The cookbook which uses these
ridiculous measurements like a scant 3/4
cup of
sugar so the first thing I'm going to do
is transform this into realistic
measurements using
wa so that's like a fun side it I don't
think it has any direct impact on
functional programming but the next
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
assume some domain knowledge I'm going
to assume that you've done a little bit
of baking before maybe you haven't made
cupcakes but you've baked something like
this before and when I do that I can now
simplify the instructions for this
recipe much much I can make that much
much
smaller and then the other thing I can
do is I can start use variables rather
than listing the things I'm going to say
beat together all the dry ingredients
mixed together the wet ingredients and
the thing that's neat about this is now
that I've reduced that recipe to the
point I can put two recipes on a single
page and this is powerful because now
you can see exactly how vanilla cupcakes
and choca cupcakes differ it's not just
that we add cocoa you can see there's
120 gam of flour here 100 G of flour and
20 G of cocoa so what we've done is
replaced flour with cocoa so this is
valuable to know now right because now
you have the slider you can control the
chocolatin of a cupcake from not at all
to EXT extremely and that that is a
that's that's a valuable Insight right
because now you're moving from just
creating a specific recipe to creating
an entire class of
recipes So What on earth does that have
to do with functional programming well
let's go back to a couple of for Loops
so I want you to look at these for Loops
again if you can see them try and figure
out what do these for Loops do what is
the same and what is different so take
30 seconds or so see if you can puzzle
out these for loops
for
so what what are both of these four
Loops do what what do they have in
common well if you read them carefully
you'll see they both basically iterate
Over The Columns of this empty cars data
frame what's different about them well
the first for Loop computes the mean and
the second for Loop computes the
median so when you use for Loops what
for Loops tend to do is emphasize the
object that are being
transformed but really in this case
those objects are the same what you want
to focus on is what's the the actions
what transformation is occurring and
that is what functional programming is
really great at so if you instead of
using your own for Loop basically what
you're going to do is you're going to
use a function that has written that for
Loop for you so all map devil does
really is it just has that for Loop
inside the function and it does it for
you so now it is much much easier to
what's going on because we've removed
all of that boiler plate that you need
every single time you write a for
Loop so this is kind of the the the
simplest the lowest level use of
functional programming I think this is
still really powerful it doesn't allow
you to do anything that you couldn't do
before but it allows you to do it with
greater ease and with a lesser chance of
creating bugs because you're lying on
someone else's
code oh so purr is a um this is my
package for doing functional programming
uh it is and it stands for
uh I kind of forget what it stands for
it stands for uh make your pure
functions per and R is five letters
because D ggv read R and something else
also has five letters so it lines up
nicely at the start of your package at
start of your code uh and it is also a
nod to the powerful our cat ladies
hashtag you do not want to angang
okay so that's like the simplest level
of a for Loop you can the simplest
application of functional programming
you can kind of move up the tower of
abstraction and do more and more
powerful things this I think is a quite
a cool idea here I'm doing a little
simulation I want to do I want to
generate a uniform distribution with a
minimum of one and a maximum well
minimum one negative one should be
maximum one there I want to generate a
random normal with a standard deviation
of five I Want A Plus on with a Lambda
of 10 and so on and I can store this in
a data frame and I think this is a
really powerful idea thinking about
functions and their parameters as data
is a really really interesting idea but
then what I can do is I can use mutate
I'm going to add a new column the
results of my simulation using the
invoke function from Pur I call each of
these functions with the parameters
specified as well as this constant
parameter for all of them that I want 10
random signs
or here's another really cool idea so
here I'm going to generate some
parameterized our markdown reports I
want to do one report for each unique
value of the class variable in the mpg
data set I want to save it to a file
called fuel-economy then the name of the
class. HTML and then the parameters to
that report is going to be my class
equals uh the the class name and then I
can use this pwalk function which is
basically going to call AR mark down
render once for each of these class
variables it's going to supply the
parameters and it's going to supply the
output file name so you're going to
easily generate multiple reports one for
each value of this
variable so that's the idea that's sort
of the idea of embracing functional
programming even at the simplest level
it allows you to replace for Loops which
are thing with things that are easier to
write and easier to read and highlight
the actions rather than the objects and
then you can up from that to
progressively more and more complicated
things which I think are still really
useful and really powerful in the data
analysis I wanted to finish off by
talking about this idea of writing for
humans which honestly I don't entirely
know what what that means except that
it's really
important and I I really like this quote
from Hal alilson uh who's a very famous
and well respected computer scientist
that really the goal of a program the
goal of code is to communicate with
other humans it's really only incidental
that the computer can go away and run
this and I think this thinking about
code AS communication is really really
important because I I mean every project
you work on is always fundamentally
collaborative because you are always
working on it with future you and if you
don't want future you to be cussing out
past you it is a really good idea to
make sure that your code not only works
but it conveys what it does it
communicates its purpose
so I've got kind of like three little
things that I think are somehow related
to this idea that you're not just
writing for for computers you're writing
for
humans so the first is these these some
of these package names so for cats is a
very new package I wrote like two weeks
ago it is a package for categorical
variables that is also an anagram of
factors and again it is a nod to the r
cat ladies community so I'm pretty sure
my P package naming skills have now
peaked that package but we've also got
MCR um inspired by the famous mcre
painting this is not a pipe we've got
tibbles we've got luid like I I I want I
want when you're doing data analysis in
r i want it to be fun it should be fun
you what you're doing is fundamentally
interesting and fun and I want the names
of the packages to have a little bit of
humor in them and some of the names of
the functions recently tibble just got a
uh a trible function so you can talk
about this trouble with
tribles I think another thing that I
that is is fun is the idea of making
sure like I I want you to like identify
a little bit as like you're someone who
not only uses art but you're proud of it
like you're excited about it you think
you know broom is cool broom's a a neat
package by David Robertson that takes
your models and turns them into tidy
data frames you're excited about ggplot
2 D per and you're not afraid to show it
by putting a sticker on your
laptop and you'll see my laptop is uh
getting kind of a little excessively
over full so I'm going to have to stop
writing packages once the the stickers
can no longer F on my
laptop so that's sort of two parts of it
there like humor this this this this
sort of human that you're not you're not
doing this alone you're part of a a clan
and then finally the sort of idea that
when you you name functions and these
are the five most important functions
from D player you know English is not
precise enough to convey all the
information to convey everything you
want with a function name but at least
think about function names that kind of
evoke the general idea that filter is
for picking variables mutate changes
your data by adding a new variable
arrange changes the order select allows
you to pick variables like thinking
carefully about how you name your
variables how you how you name your
arguments I think is is is challenging
but but extremely
worthwhile so I showed you four shared
with you four principles so you want to
share data structures across packages
the Tidy tibble is a particularly
powerful idea because most of time and
statistics and data analysis we are
working with uh variables and and cases
or observations a really good strategy
for solving complex problems is by
composing simple pieces a great way to
do that in R is the simple pieces are
simple functions that you can easily
understand and isolation and you compose
them together using the pipe and the
great thing about the pipe is that Works
across packages and the other thing
that's great about the pipe which I
didn't mention is that if you don't like
the pipe you don't have to use it it's
not it's not like the Plus in ggplot 2
which you're forced to using regardless
of whether you think it's a good idea or
not you can still do all the other ways
of composing functions you're already
used to or you can use the
pipe embracing functional programming is
important not because for Loops are bad
but because there are tools that allow
you to work with more ease that allow
you to allow you to produce code that's
easier to write and then later on easier
to understand and this fourth bullet
point which I still don't exactly know
what it means but this idea that you you
it's it's not just about the computer
right it is about other people and
thinking about those other people is
important so my kind of goal is to
create a pit of success so a pit of
success is very different to call a
pinnacle of success right because a
pinnacle of success is hard work you
have to climb that mountain to get to
the top the goal of a pit of success is
you just kind of like fall
in and I I you know I absolutely admit
that we're still a long way away from
our being this pit of success but the
idea of the Tidy verse the packages of
the Tidy verse that share these common
conventions make it more likely that you
are going to fall into this pit and be
successful so one uh along those lines
one package that I've released very very
recently like two days ago I think is
this new package called tidy verse so if
you install tidy verse this will install
all of the packages in the tidyverse so
you've got them all on your computer and
then you can also if you if you load the
tidyverse package that loads for you the
the six packages that I think are the
most important that you're likely to use
for every data analysis ggplot 2 tibble
tidd D and per it also gives you like a
convenient summary of some of the
dubious decisions that I've made to
override base functions which I will not
go into now but at least it shows you
clearly where the potential problems
might
be so I just wanted to finish off by uh
with this diagram again this to me uh
sort of the current set of packages in
the Tidy verse I want to emphasize one
of the things that people used to call
this collection of packages that work
together nicely which I can barely only
managed to say is the the Headly verse
which I really dislike because it makes
when I say it it makes me sound like an
egotistical
Maniac but the thing that's really
important is that it's not the Tidy
verse is not about me none of these
packages were created in isolation many
of these like even now like luat I
barely have anything to do with it these
days many of these packages stringr
Builds on top of the F fantastic string
ey package HDR Builds on top of there
are other packages that I have had
nothing to do with David Robinson's
broom package uh the DBI package for
talking to
databases this is not just about me this
is a collection of packages that share a
common philosophy a uniform way of
thinking about data that when you use
them together makes your life easier
thank
you
so I'm tempted to just drop the mic and
walk out cuz I actually have a mic but I
think we have time for some questions go
repeat the
question do
you g uh so the question is do I plan on
making any changes major changes to GG
blot 2 uh in general I answer I will I
have decided that is a terrible idea for
me to make promises about anything such
as like the infamous promise that 2016
was going to be the year of GG V which I
can it is not uh it is unlikely that
there are going to be uh major changes
to ggplot 2 that that change the way it
works uh I do have uh a fantastic intern
who's working on ggot 2 this summer
who's working along some of the themes
that in the last release of making gigot
2 more extensive so that other people
can build in the bits that are missing
rather than me so I wanted to highlight
along those lines one really fantastic
website uh which is the ggplot
2 uh extensions
website which lists a whole bunch of
these
add-on these new packages like uh
GG G
and the unfortunately G now this is
GG and this is g g graph uh which these
are really cool packages they extend GG
PL to to draw graphs we've got other
add-on packages that add a whole bunch
more themes if you've ever died to make
your uh gplot 2 look like a starup
package or Excel package you can do that
with GG
themes uh there's some cool ones GG all
GG repair
is really neat it adds text labels that
are automatically pushed away from each
other GG alt GG force and GG alt which
add a whole whole bunch of other little
useful tools so the kind of the goal the
thing I really want to embrace with
ggplot 2 going for there will be some
sort of little minor changes here and
there but to make it as easy as possible
for other people to extend it in the way
that works for
them I I have to say I have been like
incredibly tempted to make a gig plot 3
which would be exactly the same as
ggplot 2 but it would work with the pipe
um but I've resisted that Temptation
so along those lines why not just
overload the pipe operator
to uh so the the question was why
couldn't I just make basically the pipe
and plus somehow work together but
unfortunately it's basically impossible
for that to work would be exceedingly
difficult and
fragile is it still one line of
code
yeah the question was is it still one
line of code if it's got uh 10 pipes and
it uh I don't know there's there's
something about that kind of like
semantic chunking of information that
some like people people use there are a
lot of people who use really really big
complicated pipes which I I think I
think like once you're above like 10
Lines within a pipe it's starting to get
too complicated you should save it to an
intermediate variable and the reason you
should do that is because you can name
that intermediate variable and that that
name contain conveys information about
what you're trying to
do but that it I think that that
structure is very natural it's like a
paragraph and you can read each line
like a sentence so I don't know they
think it's easier to read than one big
like giant blob of code with no white
space but you still want to use you know
not everything needs to be in one
pipe talk more
about been a lot
of to some problem I get that
andols
learn spre the
universes
nice yeah so to summarize the question
was basically I think how did I get to
the Tidy verse and where is the Tidy
verse going and I I
think s of the way that I got here I I
think it's interesting like to me
there's
something kind of powerful about like
names and spaces um which which sounds
which is sort of very abstract but this
like I think one of the reasons that I I
never really thought so much about how
these packages fit together was people
called it the hadly verse and I just
could not stand that name so it like
avoided thinking about it but as soon as
I as soon as I caught up the Tidy verse
and sort of started to think well it's
not just individual packages but it's
how all these things fit together a sort
of shape have these things fit together
then it sort of started to become like
more obvious to me like what are what
are the pieces and how do they fit
together and you know for example that
was one of the things that led to the
development of the four cats package
because sort of obvious you've got
lubber date for dates you've got strings
for Strings string out for Strings what
do you have for
factors um so so sort of and then the
the name that helped me think about it
and then this the space like the right
it's not just stuff that lives in one
package it's this this encompassing
concept and then having the idea of this
tidyverse package which is where like
meta tidyverse stuff can live so for
example and that that that package also
contains a vignette which basically
contains a sort of Manifesto and in text
form the thing I think like going
forward I mean the hope is now that I'm
starting to make these principles
explicit and this is you know basically
my first or second attempt at doing that
and I think there'll be quite a lot of
iteration before it's like polished but
the the idea is again like making it
because it's the Tidy verse it's not the
hadly verse like everyone's invited you
can make a make a package that fits in
nicely with a tidy verse because there's
now these well elucidated set of set of
principles that you should follow
so hopefully this will s of get bigger
over
time
Shin yeah so the question sort of about
shiny and I think that really comes back
to this very first
diagram and the thing I really have not
talked about tonight is that communicate
but in in some sense I think that's
where
like our Studios doing really nice
things obviously I'm a little biased
because they pay my salary but I
wouldn't have uh joined the company if I
didn't think they're doing good stuff
like communicate to me like I think the
two tools to me that I use all the time
to communicate are markdown for
producing static reports and shiny for
creating interactive web apps now how
this how these sort of ideas maap our
markdown and shiny they they they don't
seem to translate immediately to me um I
I talk a lot with um Joe the creator of
shiny a lot a lot about these ideas and
he sort of has the if anything like the
shiny belongs to like the monad verse
which monad is a kind of this fairly
sophisticated functional programming
idea that there's um like there's a
million different tutorials written
about monads and you never it's
impossible to understand monads but as
soon as you do understand monads you
start seeing like monads
everywhere uh and you think everyone
should know about the power of monads um
so so I don't know like I I think like
the Tidy equally like the the Tidy verse
isn't the entire universe of data
manipulate this this sort of there
something they can't quite articulate
yet where it belongs but to do with that
like the process of doing data science
and then I think the process of
communicating it there's some overlap
between these universes but it's it's a
little bit different I
think
so the
the so the question was basically about
sort of performance and
um consistency and I'm going to put this
slide up
because by and large I mean my goal is
to make it easier to express these ideas
I am not as interested in making it
computationally efficient that that said
um like as my team at R Studio grows I'm
going to have the opportunity to hire
people who do care about performance and
who can work on that uh the other thing
that I think is really important is
typified by this uh sparkly r package
that oops it's just got spark. R Studio
uh so sparkly R it's a package for uh
connecting to spark
obviously but it but it but it uses the
same ideas as as deeper and one of the
things that's really neat about deeper
is it abstracts away the description of
these operations from the actual
implementation so that means you can
work with a data frame in memory with d
player in exactly the same way you can
work with a massive data frame that's
stored in spark and I and I think that
that that's really that that's really
important that you somehow you you don't
want to have these very expensive
cognitive switches between switching
between different Frameworks and and R
is such a great language for Designing
like these little domain specific
languages that then can
um then can translate to efficient code
in other ways so I guess my answer is
kind of twofold like first of all I
am like I'm not personally that
interested in performance but I know
people do care about it so as my team
grows there will be more people who are
interested in performance and then that
said like it's not like I doesn't have
to do everything but R should be able to
talk to everything and it should be able
to talk to these other tools in a way
that's very very natural and I think the
sparkly r package is a really great
example of that because you can take
everything you know about working with
in memory data frames and start applying
that to very large out of memory data
frames obviously you're going have to
learn some new stuff as well but at
least there's not this mess if you don't
to suddenly stop using R and start using
python or scolar or Java or
something you
think I mean there's there's still like
so much there's still a lot of things
that you cannot do uh with the Tidy
burst I I think there's lots of
um so the question was about the value
of of of Bas
R I don't know I I think Bas R is
this
it's this like really strong stable
solid foundation that the Tidy verse can
grow out of and the Tidy verse is like
much more like waving around in the The
Winds of fashion I guess um instead of
slowly over time parts of the Tidy verse
kind of kind of harden up as I figure
out like what works really well so to me
like base ARS is a really really strong
foundation and it also makes the Tidy
verse possible because the Tidy verse
doesn't have to solve every single
possible problem because you can still
use you can still use all of the the
thousands of other packages it's it is
the sort of ultimate shared data
structure that everyone like
uses
that clar all to our own
of
think yes so I'm going to uh paraphrase
paraphrase that
question uh into a question that I've
thought a little bit
about and struggled with and that is
like this it's still like when I do a
data analysis there's still like and and
admittedly I don't do that much data
analysis but I still do data
analysis there's sort of like surprising
there's still like a lot of duplication
right you you sort of try these
different things you want to like vary
them a little bit maybe you kind of want
to systematically vary them maybe you
just want to explore like one Avenue
that looks particularly promising and
then like how can you like kind of reuse
that both like within analysis across
your own analysis and then across like
other people's analyses like there sort
of I think there's
some like like the idea of I think the
idea of a function for a way as a way of
like wrapping up certain Behavior like
what is kind of the equivalent of a
function that allows you to encapsulate
some common pattern of of data
analysis and I really don't know what
the answer is
um the thing that makes me think of a
little bit is there's another thing that
we've been working on a little bit
lately at our studio I'm just going to
pull up
a our studio really
quickly and I think this one's okay make
that text slightly larger for
you and that's the idea of like this
sort of notebook interface so in the
development version of our
studio just going to click the
buttons we have this kind of notebook
interface and and basically this this is
this is sort of
not there's multiple different concepts
of note notebooks and this is really
focusing on like how can you use ANM
markdown document like a notebook and
and what that means is like well instead
of putting the output the printed output
on the console and the plots in a plot
pane well you get everything in the
notebook in line and there's some quite
cool stuff I don't know if I can find a
I like I'll just make a little toy
example
here just because I think this is really
cool like if you have multiple chunks
multiple things you have got a plot in a
data set you get this pretty cool little
uh Gallery widget and you can and
instead of just printing a data frame
like a typewriter you can print it like
a human
being so there's something
like like somehow like this like how to
how to use like notebook type interfaces
and I think the thing that's really
interesting to me about this and and why
this relates to your original question
is there's something about the chunk
that that seems like the chunk is kind
of the unit of composition of a data
analysis in a similar way to the
function being a unit of composition and
and
programming and and and I don't you know
I don't really know what the answer is
but that's sort of like what I'm
thinking like it seems like we're
missing something there's something
interesting with the way that chunks and
a notebook computer functions and and
programming how can we kind of bring
that together make stuff easy to share I
don't know the answer but that's
something I'm really interested
in
so the question is basically again about
um communication and particularly I
think if you're doing uh a lot of web
communication on the web and you have a
skills team who know just r or or python
but also know know JavaScript like how
do
you how do you kind of get the rest of
the process to flow into that and and
there's definitely this and there's also
this this sort of difference between
like there's different types of
communication like often a data
scientist will be commun we'll do an
analysis and we'll communicate it to
like two other people and in that case
the goal is just getting that speed of
iteration as absolutely as quick as
possible in other cases the data
scientist might be communicating to like
10,000 people also the extreme of thata
things like 538 and the opsh are
communicating with hundreds of thousands
of people
and and and I think that does
fundamentally change things because it
changes like the Rel of how much effort
are you willing to put into this
communication piece and I I I think like
I think visualization is really
important there but I just don't like
know enough about that space really
that's not really the space that I work
in to kind of to give really good advice
but again just it's like thinking about
these arrows is so important like
thinking about that process EXP
explicitly and and how you kind of how
you still do that rapid iteration for
exploration and then slowly kind of like
calcify it for whether it's production
or large scale communication I again I
think that's real those are really
interesting problems I don't know of
good
Solutions so that's this box here yeah
I'm not going to say anything about that
really
except um except I think that there's
still like modeling in R is definitely
one of its strengths but a lot of the
the modeling functions were developed
and sort of fundamentally a different
era of computing and so one thing for
example is like when you fit a model
with LM that object contains a complete
copy of the data which is just kind of
now like mindblowing but at the time was
like really a fantastic idea and really
useful and so I I I think it's kind of
it's it's sort of time to start thinking
rethinking like how modeling in R should
work and I and you know that that sort
of that couples into like all of these
other changes that that your data you
want to be able to work with the the the
key thing with working with big data is
you don't want to move the data around
you want to send the computation to the
data so if your data is in spark and you
want to fit a linear model to it you
don't want to bring the the data into R
and fit a linear model you want to seend
the that parameterization of the linear
model to spark and have it fit there and
you want to be able to do that exactly
you want to be a to fit a linear model
to a data set in the same way regardless
of whether that data set lives in spark
or lives in memory and I I don't know
what the the answers are but again those
are the sort of questions that I'm
thinking about how can you make it easy
to express modeling in a sort of backend
agnostic way like you can in
deeply I also
work
learn oh it's
atonic any advice on either how to
prevent situations or maybe Bas accept
CES
yeah that's a a good question and and
this sort of this actually like the
introduction of like this the way that
tibbles work the way that when you
subset them to get a single column you
only use a single brackets you always
get a data frame back actually pose them
sort of interesting like it broke
packages that were not in any way
related that you could not by looking at
the intersection of tibble dependencies
and these plot these other package
dependencies figure out that there might
be a possibility of breakage so I I
don't know I I think some of it is like
making sure you give feedback to me
about where things break I mean maybe I
won't care and I'll tell you it's
someone else's responsibility but um
sometimes I need to hear the same thing
multiple times before I realize it's
it's a
problem um the forcats ex the forcats
package is another really great example
of that because I think I was basically
in denial about the utility of factors
for like 5 years um and then when I
finally broke down and realized that
they were useful I discovered that they
are actually really useful but they're
just missing a few key tools uh so I
think like some of it is definitely like
tibble like some of these these packages
in the tidyverse are like deliberately
aggressive like they're aggressive that
and I do these things because they know
they are aggressive and I know they will
break things but sometimes the only way
to figure out like what's what's wrong
is to kind of break things deliberately
and get lots of people doing it and see
what breaks and then maybe back off a
little bit so that's definitely
something like feed leing back to me
like and to the the other people who
work on these packages like hey this
this is breaking and and we need to
think about like is that good or bad is
that we should we fix it or someone
should someone else fix
that otherwise I don't know I I think
like debugging is is hard and it is
particularly frustrating you know again
it's this um this trade-off between
between being conservative and and being
utopian and and some of those just
I I think you just kind of have to live
with a little bit
of pain in the shortterm pain and the
service of of long-term success and I'm
kind of on your behalf willing to cause
you a lot of pain if I think it's better
for you on the long run and maybe I'm
wrong but sometimes you just have to
break stuff in order to make it
better
so so the question was about package
Discovery like this is my attempt at
package Discovery at least putting all
those packages I think are really
important on a single side um that
that's obviously only like a drop in the
bucket right I think that is a real
problem for the our community like how
do you and and this it's not only for
the people using the packages but also
people writing packages like there's um
you know like six different logging
packages and 15 different packages for
doing density estimation and how do you
pick which one and and how do people how
do you help people work together rather
than everyone doing their own little
different thing um and I have to say
it's sort of when you look
at it's sort of interesting to me like
when I look at like the python Community
versus the r
community in some ways it's it's much
there are some parts of the Python
community that are great like everyone's
sort have standardized on Psychic learn
you've got this one Central thing that
all behaves the same way but then when
you look at like package installation
and python like because everyone who
uses or most people using python are
fundamentally programmers they install a
package and they're like oh this package
installation process sucks I'm going to
create my own package manager and then
you end up with a sort of proliferation
of all these these other tools so I
don't know I think it's it's a really
hard problem part of it is simply like
you you can't force like if three four
people want to write a package that
helps you do logging then you can't like
force them all to work together and
create one package and and some of that
is like just you know human politics and
some of it is that people are often
solving genuinely but subtly different
problems in rather than like forcing
them all to sort of shoehorn into one
structure that doesn't fit everyone very
well or you have to create some very
very generic structure that is
infinitely flexible and suits every need
but then no one understands how it works
I don't know it's a hard problem I I
think definitely on sort of the user
facing side thinking about how we can
make it easier to find packages one of
the things I am particularly interested
in that aspect is like how do you at
least when you start learning R like
what packages should you learn what
packages are are likely to make you most
successful and you know again that's the
sort of the goal of this AFA data
science book is to like lay that out
like I'm not I don't guarantee that I'm
not trying to say that this is the best
approach ever but this is a set of
packages that work well together and if
you use them you are likely to be
successful and that's kind of at least
my kind of Line in the Sand and then I
think over time there needs to be like
broader efforts like not everything is
going to be in here there's like too
many domain specific things I don't know
it's a hard problem um and I don't know
anyone um I don't know any good
Solutions
so I I think the question again I'm
going to kind of reframe the question is
it sort of a worry about like do you end
up with a sort of very monoc clonal or
mono kind of cultural environment where
everyone is using the same tools and
then you have sort of those high risk
that maybe there's a really productive
area that everyone is that know everyone
is missing because their tools are so
constrained I I basically don't really
worry about that just because the our
community is so diverse the Tidy verse
is really just a little part of that
lots of people are doing other stuff
working on all sorts of other directions
uh and and the Tidy verse is not like
this Walled Garden you can you can still
use it along with everything else
that you can do an hour maybe there's a
little bit of friction when you kind of
break outside the Tidy verse but I I
don't think it's too
awful I mean generally I sort of I
there's
this I don't know sometimes kind of
almost machismo
like this should be really hard to do so
that like dumb assers can't do it like
we want to protect this like we don't
want stupid people doing statistics cuz
they'll screw it up um and I I wrote
this paper which I I really I really
like the the the metaphor about this
which is like statisticians particularly
I think every discipline does this to
some extent but statisticians have this
kind of like have this sort of
abstinence-based approach to statistics
right you should never do statistics
unless you're in a committed long-term
relationship with a
statistician but the problem is like
everyone sees like their friends falling
around with Statistics and they're
having like a great time and nothing
goes wrong and so they just do it anyway
so you know absence based education
doesn't really work so I'm I'm all for
like so I'm sort of more in favor of
like how do you like practice safe stats
and at least like explicitly teach like
these are the pitfalls and what do you
need to watch out for but you can do it
yourself you can do really good stuff
you don't have to be a trained
statistician to pick up these tools and
and and do cool
stuff follow question
ience
so this again this sort of question
follows up about um package Discovery
and could we at our our studio use what
we know um I mean part of the problem is
we don't actually know anything about
how people use R because we and we're
very careful to not know that because we
know we don't want to be in the business
of like snooping in on what R code you
run that would be like a fundamental
kind of breach of your privacy so I'm
going to answer your question with a
another website this is the website for
the infrastructure steering committee of
the r Consortium uh we have grants
available to work on projects that
broadly benefit the art our community
and package development is clearly
something that would a package Discovery
is something that would clearly benefit
the our community so if you have like if
you hear if you're are hearing these
questions and thinking oh my God I know
how to solve this problem and it's super
easy then you should totally apply for
an IFC Grant uh they'll be closing again
um we need to update the website but
about January 10th and we have funding
available up to about 50k I think for
for big bigger projects and we have lots
of smaller grounds available on the
order of like five or
10K so I think I'll take uh one last
question before I die and um JD looks so
excited to ask me a question I have to
have you ever consider doing a QA
on I think I think possibly quora may
have ined a paid shill into the audience
uh I am in fact doing a Q&A on
quora where you can ask me anything and
I maybe I'll answer it or not I'm
already like I'm so tempted to answer
this question just
no that's a little GL uh there's some
really uh interesting questions in here
uh do you remember how many votes the
the Mother-in-law one
had the Mother-in-law one is gone there
was someone was asking me a question
like what do you do if your
mother-in-law invades your kitchen I'm
like so there's some quirky questions oh
the the income one was it
in
they seem to be like weeding out there's
some kind of wacky ones that seem to
like come up and then disappear again so
if you do have other questions uh this
would be a great place to answer them
you can ask them for like the next uh
week basically if you get enough people
to vote it up and I think it's
interesting I will answer it and
probably I don't really care about how
many votes it gets but if it's
interesting I will try and uh answer it
but some of these questions are
pretty oh my God like what was Leo
bryman trying to convey in his research
paper don't ask
me how do I make a database importing
multiple CSV files in R like C stack
Overflow anyway I will not I will uh I'm
only like poking for these questions I
won't really be mean when I ask them
seriously um but if you do have other
questions that's a great place to answer
them thanks for thanks for reminding so
thank you all for
coming so um one more round of applause
forley some things to wrap up um going
to the bar whoever wants to come someone
online requested that he couldn't hear
people announcing jobs so oh it was you
in person so if you announc the job
post it on our discussion board or post
it in the comment section meet up let
everyone see you have a job available
it's free we don't charge anything like
monster so post away actually quality
jobs um thank you again to workbench and
everyone have a great time and again
thank you to
Havey